British Military Intelligence sources
say Russian forces are now deliberately
targeting areas populated by civilians a
response to the Ukrainian resistance
which is slowing Russia's advance in
spite of these increasingly brutal
tactics volunteers including many from
outside Ukraine are signing up to join
Ukraine's army men between the ages of
18 and 60 have to stay in the country so
they're available for conscription
these men are determined to fight for
their country even in the face of
Russian Firepower and without support
from NATO
here in Kiev they're waiting to sign up
for the Ukrainian Armed Forces
resolved to do their part for the war
effort
it's my duty I want to be useful I want
to help I want to protect I want to
fight back I want my family to return to
Ukraine as soon as possible and I will
do my best
other volunteers are stocking up for the
battle ahead and optimistic about
victory
we know why we defend our country and
our guys that are actually standing
there and fighting our Russian military
forces they know what they are doing
those guys they don't
we know what we are doing and that's why
we will win
it's that determination that's helped
Inspire volunteers from much further
afield to join the fighting a military
zelenski everything is just everything's
been inspiring even though the country's
surrounding everybody's just like it's
like galvanized everybody I've got no
Illusions I've got no romantic ideas of
war or well I'm going to be some hero or
make a difference or any of this but
it's it's what I do
could die here yeah right yeah we're
going to do it's pretty worse
with heavy fighting already reaching the
city of European just outside Keith it
looks likely The volunteer's Bravery
will soon be put to the test
and despite all those volunteers the
Ukrainian military remains outnumbered
but more and more reports show that
Russia's Invasion has slowed or even
stopped in recent days Russian soldiers
have moved into Ukraine's Northeast and
South although it's not clear how much
territory they actually control columns
are getting close to the capital key
even as we heard earlier the city of
mariupole on the Black Sea has been
under siege for days
with us now from London is Ed Arnold
he's a European security expert with the
Royal United Services Institute a
defense Think Tank Ed thank you for
joining DW this morning we're now a week
and a half into the war in Ukraine
militarily how is Russia doing
so yes we're on day 11 as far
um and the Russian military
um have performed very poorly and I
think it's a very poor plan executed
also poorly
um they are their movement is very
constrained it's been very slow in some
ways it's been very complex and as
you've just highlighted in your piece
the logistics problems of supplying
Frontline troops is
hampering efforts across the country to
continue their Advance
The Invasion started and the north east
and south and we're seeing a lot better
performance to the South but in the
Northeast and North stalled and actually
in some places the Ukrainian forces are
putting in quite small scale at the
moment for very uh sophisticated
counter-attacks which is causing
corrosion advancement serious problems
said they're outnumbered are it soldiers
and it's soldiers they're still holding
their own how are they doing that
yes I mean this is a case of the
Russians performing very poorly but the
ukrainians Performing uh exemplary
um and that's both the uh Russian sorry
wrong the uh Ukrainian professional
military but also Civil Society uh the
ukrainians will to fight
um has proved decisive in the initial
phases over the weekend up until around
Monday and then as we've moved into
phase two
um they are adapting uh their Air Forces
still uh intact but depleted and like I
said they've put a a quite remarkable
counter-attack in uh around
um Cardiff and also to the west of Kiev
which is meaning that the Russian
encirclements of Kiev is taking a lot
longer in terms of the time and actually
ground forces are starting to Target the
Convoy to the north of Kiev because it's
static and very vulnerable
now there's been so much conjecture
about a no-fly zone and passion please
for and against
um if we if we say agree with those
saying no to the no-fly zone that it
will only lead to escalation then what
else should the West be doing to support
Ukraine right now
yes that's right and I think it's
important to note that there are a
variety of technical measures so you
know a no-fly zone is not just a blank
of new fly zone there's a there's a
grade in between
um but essentially what it would mean
that this moment in time is the act of
suppression of Defense assets both in
Belarus and Russia and actually new
hunting and destroying Russian aircraft
within that area which the risks of
escalation are very high they're just
this week we've seen um unfortunately
Romanian mid-21 uh go down in the Black
Sea due to mechanical issues not
actually due to enemy fire and also the
search and rescue helicopter that went
to retrieve the pilot also went down due
to bad weather so it's a case where it's
Illustrated of how these things can
actually be misinterpreted on the ground
and the fog of War so
um everyone is worried about escalation
at the moment NATO and other Western
countries are continuing the supply of
lethal Aid continuing intelligence
sharing and possibly even support seeing
Ukrainian targeting and intelligence and
decision support on the ground which is
not inconsiderable support that NATO
nations are providing
now Ukraine says it's killed more than
11 000 soldiers now that's obviously a
number that is impossible to verify at
this stage Russia only admitting to
losing several hundred what could that
mean
s yes I mean it's very difficult to
provide accurate numbers and the
Russians have only put out an official
figure in the last couple of days which
does seem very low but still in terms of
only 11 days into our operation or or
actually quite High I mean if we take uh
roughly the middle number of the Russian
reports of the Ukrainian report that's
around five thousand I mean four context
that is more than the Americans lost in
the combat operations in Iraq and that's
only in 11 days as opposed to seven
years so it is considerable um the other
thing with the Russians military is the
Pentagon now assess that 95 of their
combat power that was amassed around
Ukraine for this operation has now been
committed to the country so they don't
have a reserve which should really run
at about 30 percent it's actually now at
five so very quickly I think the Russian
plan of a whole of country strategy is
unraveling and they just might not have
the numbers to achieve the military
objectives that they might have set
themselves
Ed Arnold from Britain's royal United
Services Institute thanks very much for
your time
thank you
and let's take a look now some other
developments in the conflict credit card
Giants MasterCard and Visa say they're
suspending operations in Russia dealing
the latest blow to the increasingly
isolated countries in battle Financial
system the move follows crushing
economic sanctions imposed by the West
in response to President Putin's war on
Ukraine
Russia's largest airline state-owned
aeroflot says it will halt all
international flights except to Belarus
from the 8th of March this comes after
Russia's Aviation agency warned that
Russian planes leased from foreign
companies could be impounded under
International sanctions 33 countries
have already banned Russian aircraft
from their airspace
several Western media organizations say
they're suspending reporting in Russia
with many journalists leaving the
country the decision comes after the
Kremlin past legislation cracking down
on Independent reporting under the new
law journalists can face up to 15 years
in prison for describing Putin's attack
on Ukraine as an invasion of War